hey 42 here how much pain can the human
body actually handle and campaign become
so intense that it causes death let's
find out first we need to understand how
pain actually works there are four basic
steps to feeling pain
the first is contact of the stimulus
this is the thing which actually causes
the pain for example a knife cutting
through your finger or fire burning your
skin secondly is a reception of the pain
by your nerve endings nerves cover every
inch of your body as soon as a nerve
ending detects tissue damage or
potential tissue damage it alerts your
brain by sending a pain signal so you
can hopefully stop whatever it is that
is causing that tissue damage now this
takes us on to the third step
transmission the nerve sends a signal to
the central nervous system in your brain
which is made up of neurons and the
fourth and final step is processing your
central nervous system has been informed
of the pain signal the neurons in your
brain now communicate with each other to
determine if the threat is great enough
to warrant a pain response and if so
your brain calculates how much pain is
required your brain then acts on this
decision and you feel pain what is there
a cap to how much pain we can feel well
yes since our brain decides when and how
much pain we can feel it can also shut
it off usually it does this by shutting
itself down completely when the central
nervous system becomes overloaded
subject to torture often report passing
out when the level of pain becomes too
great to handle before modern medicine
and the invention of anesthetic it was
extremely commonplace and considered
quite normal for patients to pass out
whilst on the going and amputation what
the level of pain required to pass out
can't be measured as an exact figure
because pain is subjective and everyone
feels pain differently in the 1940s
James D Hardy tried to introduce a
standardized measurement of pain called
the dollar a meter but the idea never
caught on because
experiences pain in a unique way so the
measurements were highly inconsistent
but campaign actually kill you well
turns out it can although somewhat
indirectly you can't die from receiving
too many pain signals because your brain
will shut down and you will pass out
before it does any serious damage to
your brain cells you can however die
from shock no I'm not talking about
emotional shock there is a separate
medical condition called circulatory
shock which is caused by an acute
intense level of pain when your body
goes into shock insufficient blood and
oxygen reaches yourselves resulting in
rapid and permanent tissue damage if
shock is not treated quickly it can
cause fatal damage to your organs and
your brain and in some cases this can
result in a rather quick death in fact
during Wars medics found that
administering painkillers such as
morphine to a wounded soldier and
therefore preventing them from going
into shock could often save their life
they found that the quicker the morphine
was administered the higher the survival
rate of the wounded soldiers shock and
pain was such a lethality that during
World War two soldiers carried morphine
with them onto the battlefield as it
could often save their lives by
massively reducing pain levels after
sustaining a serious injury
so yes pain can kill you thank to the
view subscribe for more thoughty2